[Musique]
des scientifiques en conflit d'intérêts
vous pouvez pas demander à quelqu'un qui
est directement impliqué financièrement
et scientifiquement de faire une enquête
de ce style les origines du virus des
révélations troublantes deuxième partie
bienvenue à découverte
[Musique]
d'où vient le virus qui a causé la
pandémie actuelle le strass cov de tous
s'entendent pour dire que son ancêtre
lointain proviendraient probablement de
la chauve-souris rhinolophe une espèce
dont l'habitat se trouve à plus de 1600
km de one la ville chinoise où tout a
commencé
la trajectoire du virus entre la chauve
souris et les humains à wang et le
mystère que toute la planète tentent de
percer depuis un an
la semaine dernière nous vous
présentions deux hypothèses la première
accepté d'emblée dès le début de la
pandémie le virus viendrait d'un animal
vendu au marché ouamane awan lieu de la
première éclosion connu
et la seconde dénigré depuis plus d'un
an une fuite de laboratoire elle vise en
particulier l'institut de virologie
située à wuhan
l'épicentre mondial de la recherche sur
les coronavirus de type strass
ces chercheurs y ont construit une des
plus importantes collections au monde de
corona virus de type strass
nous vous avons raconté l'histoire de
ces scientifiques qui ont risqué leur
carrière et de dracé que ce groupe
d'internautes qui ont enquêté dans
l'ombre pour réhabiliter cette hypothèse
leur enquête a révélé des informations
troublantes
un manque de transparence qui inquiète
contenu d expérience risquée menée à
l'institut de virologie de wuhan des
expériences dénoncé depuis des années de
soi
jusqu'à une fonction un type
d'expérience qui vise à modifier des
virus afin de les rendre plus
transmissible ou plus mortelle
l'institut de virologie construisait des
virus chimère à partir des virus de type
ce grâce modifié pour les rendre
capables d'infecter les mêmes bêtes
l'hypothèse de la fugue de laboratoire
est longtemps restée marginale en partie
parce qu'elles embarrassent plusieurs
scientifiques et des g1
au
bord de l'aude à ce niveau
cette semaine on se penche sur l'
enquête officielle menée par l' oms pour
trouver l'origine du virus et les
impasses scientifiques et politiques
auquel elle se bute
les failles de cette enquête font
craindre le spectre d'un futur possible
une prochaine pandémie causée par des
virus créé par l'humain
[Musique]
en avril 2020 l'australie est le premier
pays à mener la charge elle presse les
ems de mener une investigation
indépendante sur l'origine du virus
hu la chine en est offusqué jeunes
qu'aux fans sont elles pénalisent
l'australie par des sanctions
commerciales le ton est donné
l'inph à one est un des plus grands
experts du sras son monde il à
investiguer sur l'origine de toutes les
récentes épidémies issus de la chauve
souris le nie pas le maire le strass est
à présent le ska cov 2 pour lui ce
nouveau coronavirus est d'origine
naturelle reste en trouver la source
afin que
en mai 2020 l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé réclame l'identification de la
source au nautic du virus et sa voix
d'introduction dans la population
humaine
philippe à la sauce est experte en
menaces biologiques au king's college de
l'ombre elle conseille régulièrement
l'onu sur ces questions
là
après des semaines de négociations
confidentielles entre l'om et épique 1
en novembre 2020 le mandat est rendue
publique on parle à présent d'une étude
conjointe et non plus d'une enquête
waze
des manettes
le mandat se concentre sur l'hypothèse
naturel du virus mais aussi sur une
autre hypothèse la voie des aliments
congelés vendu au marché ou anal une
hypothèse soutenue par le gouvernement
chinois
allait natcan et post doctorants ou
broad institute associé à un om haïti
elle a été une des premières voix
scientifiques à réclamer publiquement
une discussion ouverte sur la
possibilité d'une fuite de laboratoire
le coaching process
et frozen black of meat benchs est
intéressant
si cette hypothèse s'avère le virus
proviendrait alors des pays qui exporte
ses produits congelés ce qui
innocenteraient la chine
depuis 20 ans le docteur daniel aussi
parcourt le monde pour se rendre au lieu
d'émergence des nouveaux virus afin
d'étudier les épidémies et leur origine
ils étaient sur le terrain pour les
débuts de l'ebola du maire ce du strass
du sica
nulle part le mandat ne mentionne la
possibilité d'une fuite de laboratoire
les fender perspectives
pour mener cette mission la chine
forment une équipe de 17 personnes qui
devra collaborer avec 17 experts nommés
par le ms
mais l'om s accordent à la chine un
droit de veto sur le choix des membres
de sa propre équipe
aspects et cette équipe ne comptera
aucune expertise spécifique en
biosécurité de toutes les candidatures
américaine proposait une seule sera
retenue peter d'azac présidente hickory
of alive un partenaire financier de
longue date de l'institut de virologie
de waele
il avait aussi orchestré cette lettre
qui qualifiait de complotiste la théorie
d'une fille de laboratoire il y avait
des conflits d'intérêts évidents à
l'intérieur même de la délégation m s
les virologues français etienne de
creully et bruno canard étudient le
virus sras skov du depuis le début de la
pandémie il défend la nécessité
d'étudier toutes les hypothèses sur
l'origine du virus vous ne pouvez pas
demander à quelqu'un qui est directement
impliqué financièrement personnellement
et scientifiquement à de faire une
enquête de ce style
peter d'azac doit défendre sa
participation à l'étude à répétition
[Musique]
janvier 2021 un an après le début de la
pandémie l'équipe internationale
d'enquêteurs arrive enfin à one elle y
restera quatre semaines dont deux en
quarantaine
et on sauve les in fine
visite des hôpitaux et laboratoires de
pouan un musée commémorant la guerre de
one contre le virus
les marches id one to one alors fermé
au coeur de ce voyage des échanges avec
les chercheurs chinois hilare
présenteront le travail fait par plus de
1000 experts et travailleurs de la santé
chinois avec des limites majeur
au mineur
c'est avec cette escort qu'à la fin de
leur mission ils visitent l'institut de
virologie
et sans jouer les as de w
le rapport final de la mission est
publié en mars 2021 oui tout cas
systématique approach to locate rule du
prothésiste
de
l'étude concluent qu'une fuite de
laboratoire est extrêmement peu probable
elle est jugée moins crédible que la
voix des aliments congelés qui est
qualifié de possibles une transmission
directe de la source animale à l'humain
est dit possible à probable une origine
naturelle via un autre intermédiaire un
animal inconnu et jugé probable à très
probable
line found défend ce rapport
à
2009 cloud
mais immédiatement après la présentation
des conclusions de la mission dans un
volte face inattendue
le directeur général de l'om est en
reconnaît les faiblesses la chine n'a
pas partagé adéquatement ces données et
hypothèses de laboratoire passe et
étudier les poteaux 6
nous avons demandé une entrevue à tous
les enquêteurs internationaux de la
mission ainsi qu'à l'om est ce trou sans
exception ont décliné notre invitation
les faiblesses du rapport sont
immédiatement dénoncés par une quinzaine
de pays dont le canada et les états-unis
et dans le wall street journal une
vingtaine de scientifiques remettent en
question les conclusions dont bruno
canard et étienne de creully ce rapport
dit que l'hypothèse d'un accident de
laboratoire est très très improbable
mais il n'y a pas d'élément finalement
factuelle qui documentent 7
cette conclusion car si le régime du
virus est bien naturel il devra se
trouver des traces de son parcours quels
sont donc les indices trouvés sur le
terrain qui soutiennent cette hypothèse
après la pause le marché d'animaux
vivants ouanane premier suspect
[Musique]
le marché ouanane au coeur de one
dès le départ il est considéré comme le
lieu d'origine du sras skov de tout
portait à croire que le virus se
seraient transmis à l'humain par
l'intermédiaire d'un animal vendu au
marché c'est là où auraient été infectés
le patient zéro
mais d'entrée de jeu les enquêteurs de
ms questionne véritable rôle du marché
dans leurs rapports y relève plusieurs
signes laissant croire que le virus
était plus répandue en décembre 2019 que
ce qui était rapporté et ce bien avant
l'éclosion au marché one aurait des
sommes
ou
un blog ceinture recueille plus de 200
millions par année qui pourrait révéler
si le virus circulait avant les premiers
cas rapportés
la réponse pourrait aussi se trouver
dans les soixante seize mille dossiers
médicaux de patients ayant consulté des
hôpitaux de one à l'automne 2010 9 mai
la chine a refusé cet accès aux
enquêteurs invoquant des raisons de
confidentialité alors promet des
analyses approfondies qui sont encore à
ce jour non disponibles
devant cette impasse les enquêteurs ne
peuvent que se tourner vers le marché
ouanane pour beaucoup encore le lieu
d'émergence du virus le plus probable
de
cet animal l'autre intermédiaire
porterait alors le virus progéniteurs ou
proximale le parent immédiat tu seras
skov deux projets
pour l'épidémie demers en 2013 loot
intermédiares était le dromadaire pour
le premier sera ce c'était la civette
palmiste vendus dans les marchés
des
cds pp
ça soit le problème c'est que la chine a
toujours soutenu qu'aucun mammifères
vivant était vendu au marché one
centre vérifications les enquêteurs
affirment dans leur rapport n'avoir
trouvé aucune preuve la présence de
mammifères vivant au marché en 2009
le 7 juin dernier une nouvelle étude
secoue la crédibilité du rapport de l'
oms entre 2017 et 2019 elle recense de
nombreuses espèces de mammifères vivant
en vente dans une dizaine d'étals au
marché
photos à l'appui
parmi les mammifères retrouver des
chiens vivre un décideur palmistes des
visons des animaux susceptibles sera
skov de ou impliqués dans la propagation
du premier tracé
lundi ce qu'attendait robert gary ce
virologiste est un expert des maladies
émergentes
il fait partie des premiers à avoir
examiné les séquences génétiques du
strass cov 2 pour lui aucun doute ce
virus bien de ce marché
mais pour démontrer hors de tout doute
que le virus est issu du marché il
aurait fallu tester ces animaux vivants
et trouver des traces du strass cov 2
or le 31 décembre 2019 les autorités
chinoises ont forcé la fermeture du
marché et sa désinfection
le centre de contrôle des infections
chinois le cdc déclare qu'avant cette
désinfection 3 136 échantillons ont été
prélevés sur les animaux du marché et
testé tous se sont révélés négatifs
mais puisque la chine n'a jamais admis
que des manifs est vivant et est en
vente au marché ou van hamme elle ne
peut donc admettre en avoir testé
ici
que faire alors pour démontrer l'origine
naturelle du virus l'autre piste à
suivre est celle de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du marché one mais
selon des témoignages d'éleveurs et de
trappeur chinois très tôt la chine a
ordonné la vente ou l'abattage des bêtes
les scientifiques chinois rapportent
avoir testé 80 mille animaux sauvages et
d'élevage
et tout le débat est là est toute la
question est là c'est comment ça se fait
qu'on appelle identifie cet hôte
intermédiaire alors qu'on a
échantillonné +90 l'échantillon b ce
qu'il ya des trous dans la raquette de
l'échantillonnage est ce qu'on n'a pas
et championne et au bon endroit rien
n'indique que ces tests ont été menés de
manière systématique sur les
fournisseurs et les chaînes
d'approvisionnement du marché one
d'ailleurs le rapport de l'om est en
fait sa recommandation pour la prochaine
étape d'une éventuelle enquête
[Musique]
cette absence de preuves et troublante
surtout en comparaison avec les
pandémies passées pour le maire ce lot
intermédiaire a été identifié neuf mois
après le début de la pandémie pour le
premier sera ce prouver c'est tout
intermédiaire fut encore plus rapide et
une femme m'a
marqué
on a bien trouvé récemment dans des
chauves souris au laos à 2000 km2 où
anne plusieurs virus apparentés oussera
skov de l'un serait plus rapprochée
génétiquement que ceux connus jusqu'à ce
jour mais ces virus sont encore éloignés
du virus proximale recherché et ne
possède pas une des caractéristiques
génétiques clé attendu
[Applaudissements]
plus les mois passent plus les chances
de trouver l'ancêtre immédiat du sras
skov de diminuer nom de ce type
les échantillons de la banque de sang de
one ne sont conservées que deux ans les
animaux d'élevage meurent les indices
s'évapore
malgré cet effort international le flou
plane encore sur les premiers moments de
cette pandémie qui a causé plus de 4
millions de morts les clés sont détenus
par la chine sans sa coopération la
recherche de l'origine du virus on
arrive à une impasse
au
printemps 2000 21 sans preuve tangible
de l'origine naturelle du virus de plus
en plus de scientifiques et de
politiciens prennent au sérieux
l'hypothèse de laboratoire les
frustrations de pubis deviennent
publiques la colère monte
après la pause les expériences risqués
dans des conditions de biosécurité
insuffisante
[Musique]
printemps 2021 d'un côté les découvertes
dérangeante de drastiques s'accumulent
ils font l'objet de publications
scientifiques
de l'autre les preuves de l'origine
naturelle demeure introuvable au milieu
comme titre
le principal argument qui demeure la
confiance inébranlable de grands
virologiste envers chez only girl
in fine ami de longue date de shengli la
défense
rencontre groupe even before the world
now and then à
à l'inaction organise une lettre
réclamant une véritable enquête
internationale avec une attention égale
porté à la fuite de laboratoire
cette fois à linate chat n'est plus seul
des scientifiques de renom unissent leur
voix à la sienne en mai 2021 la lettre
est publiée dans la prestigieuse revue
science cet appui formel des
scientifiques pour la thèse l'a fait de
laboratoire marque un point tournant
dans la discussion publique de grosses
primes itunes push to reduce the one of
hope you like we la petiote deux
semaines plus tard le nouveau président
américain joe biden donne 90 jours aux
services de renseignement pour enquêter
sur les véritables origines du virus
[Musique]
mais admettre qu'une fuite est possible
c'est forcer l'ouverture de la boîte de
pandore l'examen de conscience à lui en
particulier aux états unis le moteur
financier mondial de la recherche sur le
gan fonction des modifications
génétiques parfois risquées sur des
virus dangereux pourtant dénoncée depuis
plus de 20 ans et le
forcing
en février 2021 au sénat le docteur
anthony facci est confronté sur le
financement américain des expériences de
gamme fonctions à l'institut de
virologie de wuhan
le sénateur brandão fait référence à ces
articles scientifiques l'un publié en
2015 menée aux états unis en
collaboration avec l'institut de
virologie de one et l'autre publié en
2010 est mené à one dans les deux il est
écrit que ces études sont financées par
le naïade dont anthony faraci et le
directeur
malgré cela le docteur pham chi au
défenseur de longue date du gan fonction
ni nos
fans game of funk and research
institute
à
12 h
le biologiste et bright se bat depuis
plus de vingt ans pour une meilleure
régulation des expériences de gan
fonctions ce financement américain est
d'autant plus compromettants qu'une
partie aurait été accordée alors qu'ils
étaient en vigueur un moratoire sur le
financement des expériences de gan
fonction
tout
le gouvernement américain se défend
up is
not being
fonctions c'est une bataille de
définition
linfa wang siège sur le comité
consultatif scientifique de l'institut
de virologie de one il refuse de
qualifier leur expérience de gan
fonctions
richard d'autres est en désaccord
définition objective is nobody est
ce que c'était pour vous du gan
fonctions yes si maureen hobson
dénoncent les risques de la recherche
sur le guen fonction depuis plus d'une
décennie
vous l'utilisez les manipulations de
l'abattoir pour fait un virus qui nous
fait pas l'homme qui est pas vous vos
interventions est désormais une facture
paul on s'assied guen fonctions
pour plusieurs le financement de
l'institut de virologie de one pendant
ce moratoire est la preuve d'un laxisme
du gouvernement américain et richard et
bright a recensé plusieurs autres
crèches
cette incapacité d'identifier ses
recherches à haut risque inquiète
d'autant plus qu'elle s'ajoute selon
plusieurs un manque d'encadrement des
conditions de biosécurité
l'institut de virologie a souvent mis
l'accent sur son nouveau laboratoire de
sécurité maximale de niveau p4 et ses
mesures exceptionnelles de sécurité
de l'aveu même de chizé guy en entrevue
et selon ses publications ces recherches
sont menées en p2 seulement
lorsque drastique attire l'attention sur
ces conditions c'est le choc
aucune loi n'empêche les chercheurs de
mener ses expériences parmi les plus
risqués qui existe dans ses laboratoires
de moindre sécurité
et rien ni personne ne force les
laboratoires à divulguer la nature de
leurs travaux leur carnet de notes et
les accidents survenus des pratiques qui
auraient permis de lever le doute sur
les expériences menées à l'institut de
virologie de renault
il y a lieu de s'inquiéter des
conditions de sécurité à l'institut de
virologie de ou anne comme l'ont révélé
des câbles diplomatiques américains
divulgués par le washington post
il révèle une inquiétude profonde
l'ambassadeur américain à pékin le 19
janvier 2018 il note un manque important
de techniciens adéquatement formés pour
opérer les laboratoires
tour d'europe
cet été l'espoir de trouver une réponse
était entre les mains du service de
renseignement américains en ou après
trois mois d'enquêté ils déposent leur
rapport
à andy n'a ni des
non plus ne parviennent pas à trancher
les 17 agences impliquées sont
profondément divisés
le ms va entamer une phase ii à la
recherche de l'origine du virus louis
mis une formation de six trophées norris
l'europe waouh mais la chine s'y oppose
voici là où nous en sommes deux
hypothèses beaucoup de spéculations
aucune preuve définitive
pour démontrer une origine naturelle la
pièce marquante et la trace d'un virus
progéniteurs dans un autre intermédiaire
ou dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement du
marché de roanne pour une fille de
laboratoire ce serait dans les bases de
données ou des carnets d'expérience des
laboratoires dans les deux cas on peut
obtenir ses preuves ni parle en quête de
la ms ni par aucune autre régulation
internationale en petit haut sécurité
[Musique]
quand on est cadre ou non
sans mécanisme efficace pour inquiéter
les faits de laboratoire ou les origines
des épidémies on est condamné à
reproduire le passé ou même à faire pire
après la pause prévenir la prochaine
pour dean
[Musique]
juillet 2021 c'est au tour de pékin de
réclamer à l'om est ce une investigation
cette fois des laboratoires américains
logo mais bastiaens chez jean ciel et
l'eau chaude
madior
rappelle que des laboratoires menant des
expériences risques et il s'en trouve
dans bien d'autres pays
philippe alan doss a publié cette année
une cartographie mondiale des
laboratoires haute sécurité de type p 4
là où on manipule les pathogènes les
plus dangereux de la planète
elle dénombre 59 laboratoire de sécurité
maximale de type p 4 répartis dans 23
pays et il n'existe encore aucune
estimation du nombre de laboratoires de
type p 3
dénombrant forte croissance depuis 2001
jazzmen et
andrés
philippe alan doss a recensé les mesures
de biosécurité qui régissent les
laboratoire p4 existants les trois
quarts ne respectent pas les meilleures
pratiques de biosécurité
l'enjeu est d'autant plus inquiétant que
la multiplication de ces laboratoires
haute sécurité devrait s'accélérer
à l'été 2020 en pleine pandémie la chine
a annoncé la construction d'une
vingtaine de nouveaux laboratoires pie 4
et 88 laboratoire p3 plus on a deux
laboratoires de type dsl 4 bien plus on
travaille sur des virus qui
potentiellement sont très dangereuses
dans l'espèce humaine
et les accidents de laboratoire son
cours a cédé 6
on en a vu partout dans le monde aux
états unis de h5n1 d'anthrax au royaume
uni de variole en europe de prion de
vache folle
inexorablement on avance vers le jour
que nous avons des ça c'était made in de
l'auberge si c'est pas maintenant sa
tion trois ans en cinq ans la puissance
de feu que technique génétique aulas
c'est incroyable
le feu sacré qui mène ce nom mais qui ne
disposent ni ouvrir
en 2017 les états unis ont levé le
moratoire sur les expériences de cannes
fonctions
en imposant des évaluations de risques
et bénéfices pour toute nouvelle
expérience
une politique qui n'est pas appliquée
selon richard price
[Musique]
si l'on veut prévenir la prochaine
pandémie une réflexion s'impose peu
importe la provenance du virus qui
causent la pandémie actuelle
qu'elles soient liées à la destruction
des habitats écologiques et le commerce
des espèces sauvages ou aux expériences
dangereuse en laboratoire sans
encadrement suffisant il m'a
[Musique]
dit
à
cette vaste enquête internationale des
autres institutions des nations les plus
puissantes des scientifiques et
internautes rebelles ce travail n'a pas
permis de trouver ce qu'on cherche à
l'origine du virus mais il nous a appris
beaucoup sur les failles béantes en
biosécurité et en législation sur les
faiblesses de l' oms et comment même
dans les plus hautes sphères de la
science il peut être difficile de
discuter ouvertement et rationnellement
de ska
ouédraogo
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à découverte
changement climatique effet en 2018 on a
battu les records de feux de forêts dans
le monde entier
voilà c'est ainsi que se terminent les
missions d'aujourd'hui de la part de
toute l'équipe merci d'avoir été là
bonsoir
[Musique]